so why am I dressed up for this review
because I felt like it you're welcome
guardians of the galaxy is one of my
most anticipated movies of this year I
was so excited to see it in a very early
screening it's directed by James Gunn
and stars Chris Pratt Zoe Saldana the
voice of Bradley Cooper the voice of Vin
Diesel as well as Bautista himself john
c reilly and Glenn Close amazing cast in
this movie this is a bit of a gamble for
Marvel because these characters are as
well known as Captain America Iron Man
The Incredible Hulk a lot of people
haven't heard of the guardians of the
galaxy they're a ragtag group of outlaws
that come together because they all have
one thing in common they do not like
this dude named Ronan and he wants
something that's gonna help him control
the galaxy they have it so you know they
fight and stuff now we've seen a premise
like this quite often in a Marvel movie
or in a superhero movie or any movie
like this of any kind there is some kind
of object plot device MacGuffin
something everyone wants it so
everyone's gonna go after it and you
know explosions and all that stuff but
we have never seen it in a movie like
this guardians of the galaxy is
everything I wanted it to be it is
awesome this is by far
Marvel's funniest movie to date I'm
being serious like I'm completely
serious movies really freaking hilarious
like I was gut-busting laughing every
other scene this movie is just as much
of a comedy as it is an action-adventure
movie the comedy in fact even over
weighs it to the point where I would
actually just call this movie a comedy
it is truly hilarious and the jokes are
very clever and unexpected because it
takes those genre cliches those big
moments you expect countdowns and evil
stares and big face offs and moments
where you're supposed to be like
white-knuckling it and then it just does
something hilarious totally out of the
blue then on paper you'd be like this is
absolute and then you look at it
you're like wait a second this is not
absolute because this is totally
different is it completely different
from everything we've done before we
should do this in the movie we should
put this in the movie it's not that
would be awesome let's do it and then
they just do it it's like whatever they
think of
that's awesome they did they didn't care
they just did it Chris Pratt is
fantastic in this movie not only is he
very funny which he has been in the past
but his character has a lot of heart to
him and you really care about him and
I'm not just saying this because I like
Marvel movies and superhero stuff he's
really good in this movie like a very
good interesting character that you can
get behind
he's like an amalgamation of Luke
Skywalker and Indiana Jones all in one
Zoe Saldana is fantastic as Gamora she
has a very cool backstory which if you
don't know anything about I'm just not
gonna spoil it for you she added a lot
of depth to the movie speaking of death
Bautista as Drax Wow the best wrestler
turned actor since the rock so funny and
his character had a lot of depth and you
did care about him Groot
alright doesn't say much in the movie
but he was a very likable presence he
was basically like the Chewbacca of this
movie except with more humor now there
was one particular member of the
guardians of the galaxy that I have left
out so far and that is Rocket Raccoon
why have I left him out because he could
be the Jar Jar Binks of this movie he
literally could ruin this movie this
movie is honestly riding on his
shoulders so is he the Jar Jar Binks to
this movie he's the Heath Ledger Joker
of this movie Rocket Raccoon is one of
the coolest if not the coolest character
I've seen in a movie so far this year
I did not see CGI it was so well done
and Bradley Cooper has the voice
flawless you get behind the story
there's an emotional pull to the movie
which I haven't even gotten into yet
because I just want you to experience it
but it is there and you care about these
characters the action is handled very
well just as good as joss whedon handled
it in the Avengers I do have but one
issue with this movie and unfortunately
it is the villain the way that I think
that could have improved him as a
character for this movie was make him
just as oblivious and hilarious to
everything as everyone else in the film
is he's just a bad guy he's just a bad
guy and he does evil stuff and you know
he's bad if they would have included
some of the humor into his character I
think it would have worked a lot more as
a villain that is my only problem with
this movie it is kind of a big one but
unfortunately that is the way it is I'm
spoiled with Loki besides that guardians
of the galaxy is one of the most
entertaining films I have seen all year
it is endlessly enjoyable to
watch the special effects are terrific
the 3d is also very very good and
actually worth seeing and the characters
oh my god the characters are just in the
soundtrack I forgot to mention the
soundtrack and so much to this movie
it's like Cowboy Bebop
Firefly Star Wars and Indiana Jones just
all of the ones is exploding with
awesomeness engines in my pants because
it was just come worthy yeah I went
there
guardians of the galaxy gets an A it's
amazingly awesome I can't quite give it
an A+ because of that villain I gotta
stick to my guns here but besides that
love love love love love this movie
definitely check it out guys now I made
an announcement in my review for
Hercules that I'm actually going to be
going to LA the start of August I'm
actually going to be sent to LA for a
press junket for the TNT show legends or
I'm going to get to interview mr. Sean
Bean himself oh my goodness what's
happening I don't know but I'm excited
about it and I'm going to post a video
on my channel and I'm excited to do that
I really hope you guys come along with
me on this ride and thank you so much
for supporting me over the years it's a
really really great opportunity for me
and I'm excited to take part in it so
thank you very much guys if you see this
movie which you must be sure to let me
know what you think of it below and as
always thank you so much for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck Benoist